IN MAR-A-LAGO.
IN THE INTIMATE SETTING OF AIR
FORCE ONE TODAY THERE WAS
SOMEBODY NOTICEABLY MISSING
MELANIA TRUMP.
THE FIRST LADY DID NOT JOIN
JAPANESE FIRST LADY AS SHE
TOURED.
SHE WAS NOT THERE.
SO KATE BENNETT IS WITH ME IN
WASHINGTON.
FIRST QUESTION, THIS IS SUCH A
BREAK IN TRADITION, RIGHT?
THE ROLE OF THE FIRST LADY IS TO
HOST, TO ENTERTAIN IN
WASHINGTON.
WHERE WAS MELANIA TRUMP?
>> Reporter: THAT WAS THE BIG
QUESTION MARK, THIS IS
TRADITIONALLY THE FIRST LADY
DOES WHEN A DIGNITARY COMES FROM
A FOREIGN NATION, TYPICALLY IT
FALSE TO THE FIRST LADY, THEY GO
TO A MUSEUM, A SCHOOL, THINGS
SORT OF A TRADITION, TODAY MRS.
TRUMP WHO IS STAYING IN NEW
YORK, UNTIL BARRON FINISHES THE
SCHOOL YEAR, DID NOT JOIN MRS.
ABE THIS MORNING WHICH MADE IT
AWKWARD TO DO THE EVENTS ALONE,
WE HAVE SEEN MRS. ABE WITH
MICHELLE OBAMA, A